- Write a composition on the subtle
philosophy of the round and-
No.
(mellow percussion music)
- [Narrator] The gaokao is China's intense
two-day college entrance exam.
Students' marks on the
exam are said to determine
their entire future life opportunities
and earning potential in China.
With the belief that those
who Excel on the test
will have the best careers
and even marriage prospects.
College entrance is especially
competitive in China,
where the top universities only select
as few as 1 in 50,000 students.
- Wow!
That's pretty low.
That's like 0.002%?
- [Narrator] The test is so important
that factories and buildings
will shut down while the exam is underway
as police cars patrol
to keep streets quiet.
Ambulances are placed
outside exam facilities
in case of nervous collapses.
The multiple choice questions
are notoriously hard
with questions such as...
- Last October,
President Xi Jinping said that
while art is based on imagination,
- It should still be down-to-earth.
- There may be hundreds
of ways to create art,
the best way, however,
is to trace back to the
people's daily lives
and create something based off that.
- From a materialism point
of view, this is because
One, art originates from
the daily lives of people.
Two, art depends on innovation.
Three, the way art reflects on society
and its style is unified.
Four, art is a form of ideology
that reflects people's lives
while at the same time serving the people.
- God, this is confusing.
- I don't-
I have no idea.
- It's like kind of a logic question,
but it's also a grammar question
and it's also related to
current events and politics?
- Just reading this gives me anxiety
so I can understand why people
have ambulances outside.
- I don't know.
I'm gonna say A.
- I'm gonna go B,
one and four.
- D.
- [Man] You're correct!
(bell ding)
- Heck yeah!
- But literally, it's
saying the same thing.
- [Narrator] The gaokao
has been seen as symbolic
of the Chinese education
system as a whole,
and both the exam and the system itself
have been criticized for putting
impossible pressures on teens.
Outbreaks of suicides
accompany every exam season.
- Wow.
- If your whole life depends on this exam,
that's so much pressure
for one person to handle,
especially if you're
still growing as an adult.
- I mean if this one test determines
what happens in your life,
that is really intense.
- [Narrator] The exam also
includes a number of essays
with prompts than can
be notoriously obtuse,
such as...
- Do butterfly wings have colors?
- Hold up.
- Why is this an essay question?
Who do you admire the most?
A biotechnology researcher,
- A welding engineer technician,
- Or a photographer.?
What the heck?
That's just a personality question.
- I'm so stressed.
- [Narrator] Cheating has
been a rampant problem,
including the use of spy cameras
and radio devices to transmit
questions and answers.
Those who are caught cheating
may spend up to seven years in prison.
To try to prevent students
from pursuing their
increasingly creative methods of cheating,
drones have been used as hall monitors.
- Whoa!
- Drones!
- People are cheating so much
that they have drones in charge?
- This reminds me of Minority Report,
like robots are surveillance.
- The containers for milk
are always square boxes.
Containers for mineral water
are always round bottles.
- Round wine bottles are
usually placed in square boxes.
- Write a composition
on the subtle philosophy
of the round and square.
Oh my God,
what?
These are so broad!
What do you even say here?
- I think just humanity has gotten
way too obsessed with tests.
There are other ways to evaluate people.
- Compared to what we
have here in America,
we're pretty, pretty lucky.
- It just seems like if
you're putting so much
pressure on a young kid,
about a standardized test,
something's not right.
- I hope they relax their
systems at some point because
I can't imagine even going through that.
- [Male Interviewee] I'm
just thinking more about
what is the sole philosophy
of the round and square?
(lighthearted music)